moving forward what are you doing
differently in your investing portfolio
given
the fed situation inflation geopolitical
conflict all these different components
that are playing out are you changing
anything in your investment portfolio
no not really i mean everything my
strategy was working out beautifully
uh up until
uh the russia i mean uh our our value
stocks our dividend-paying stocks were
on fire defensive stocks our gold stocks
were creeping higher
uh now they're moving up the gold stock
the gold portion of my portfolio has now
kicked in a lot better the gold stocks
are doing better
some of my stocks like my you know some
of my oil stocks are making new highs
some of them are having trouble because
of their russia connections i have some
agriculture and other base metal stocks
that are making new highs
but a lot of my defensive names my
telcos my tobaccos some of these other
chemical companies that i had that were
doing well are getting hit now because
of uh
the russian concerns i think i think
it's being overblown for the european
market and the euro and so we are
looking to add to those positions on
this weakness and we did anticipate some
weakness so we did have some some dry
powder there uh you know we're still
positive on the year in our funds and
our strategies which is great because
hardly anybody else is making money and
and that's on the long side i mean we're
not short we're still making money long
uh because on average you know what
we're long is still going up even if
it's some of it is having some problems
now
with uh with the situation but i think
the u.s market has a long way to go down
relative to europe and asia i think you
know it's been defying gravity we had a
bounce in these tech stocks
they were selling off pretty hard before
uh russia and i think they're going to
continue to sell off after this balance
that would include bitcoin you know
bitcoin and some of these other beating
down money losing companies i did have a
bounce i mean bitcoin got down as low as
maybe 33 34 000. then it rallied back up
to 44 000 45 000 uh and i think that
rally has run its course you know tech
stocks and other risk assets like
bitcoin are getting ready i think to to
roll over and we're you know we're we
don't have those we have very we have no
waiting to tech i have a very very low
waiting to the financials way
underweight there they've been getting
hit pretty hard
um i expect that to continue but i may i
may have to look in that direction at
some point
but we're loaded up on materials and and
that's what's doing well inflation
sensitive and i like the businesses that
have the pricing power you know the
companies that are going to be able to
weather inflation because their
customers are just going to pay higher
prices they're going to they're just
going to cut back someplace else so i
don't want to own the companies that are
discriminate consumer discretionary the
items that can be foregone because
you're spending too much money on food
and energy but i'm confident again that
we're gonna get the fed uh pivoting its
monetary policy uh they're they're going
to surrender to inflation they're not
going to you know best it in some kind
of paul volcker style battle because
it's impossible so inflation is going to
be here for a long long time it's going
to be a new reality as par as the the
american experience
and people are going to have to adjust
to high inflation the way people in
argentina adjust to high inflation and
you just have to try to figure out how
to deal with it
unfortunately because it's not going to
go away because there is no political
will to do what's necessary
to solve that problem so we're all going
to be dealing with a much bigger problem
but you know i feel bad for people who
think that they're taking refuge in
bitcoin i mean a lot of the bitcoin guys
understand the problem uh they just
don't understand the investment solution
for themselves because they put their
faith
into into bitcoin as if the whole world
is just going to magically move from a
fiat standard to a bitcoin standard that
ain't gonna happen
you know just like you know we're we
still need fossil fuels we still need
oil and gas
you know we still need gold we still
need silver uh bitcoin ain't gonna cut
it you know it derives all of its value
from faith and this is not a time for
faith this is a time
to rely on on real facts and real value
in history not just make a pie in the
sky bet
that all your father fellow holders are
never going to sell you know you're just
buying into something on the belief that
nobody's going to sell it well if nobody
sells it what good is it because it
doesn't do you any value
you can you can have your gold and you
can sell it because there's always going
to be demand for gold you don't need
people constantly huddling it because
there's there's real demand and and
people are making stuff out of gold
every day nobody makes anything out of
bitcoin and no one ever will make
anything out of bitcoin so when people
stop believing in it you know it's it's
going to implode right now you know
you've still got this you know
opportunity to get out i mean look at
these prices don't look at 39 000
bitcoin and think that it's cheap
because it was 69 000.
think about how expensive it was because
it used to be nothing it came from zero
and it's going to go back to zero you
know like that you know for you know you
you kids for your the life cycle you
know you start out as dust and you and
then you return to dust same thing's
gonna happen with bitcoin from dust to
dust hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time